- So, what's going to happen
with the second impeachment trial
of former President Donald Trump?
Well, at this point, it's
sort of anyone's guess.
Because, remember, the
Senate basically negotiates
the rules every time they do it.
And in this case, something
really weird is going on,
because Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court John Roberts
is not going to preside over the trial.
Instead, it's going to be
democratic Senator Patrick Leahy.
And that seems weird,
because the Constitution
seems to contemplate
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court.
Now, experts disagree,
but in the case of a former president,
it's not entirely clear that
the Supreme Court justice
must actually preside.
And since the Senate
is basically making up
the rules as they go along,
it's probably going to be okay,
and frankly, it would
be a political question
if anyone tried to challenge
it in court anyway.
So, we'll see what happens
with this new impeachment,
and I'll see you in court.